questa è la storia appunto di un ponte
straordinario partiamo subito da un
presupposto che non necessariamente un
ponte qualcosa che collega due punti su
una superficie
questo è infatti un ponte particolare al
punto da giacere nelle profondità
dell'oceano atlantico ed è un ponte
molto particolare perché si tratta di un
cavo
anzi dal titolo un po ambiziosetto nella
presentazione che vedete alle mie spalle
questo ha l'ambizione di essere il cavo
che ha cambiato il mondo e questo è un
po il gomitolo di storie che si
incastrano una con le altre che racconta
questa incredibile avventura scientifica
e partiamo da una foto che è questa qui
che ritrae un soldato perché questa di
fatto potrebbe diventare la storia di un
ufficiale della marina
perché chi è che viene rappresentato in
questa foto
il soldato nella foto che abbiamo appena
visto risponde al nome di matthew
fontaine mori che appunto era all'inizio
della sua carriera un giovane avviato
verso una brillante carriera nella
marina americana
tutto questo fino al giorno in cui non
viene coinvolto in un incidente
drammatico uno di quegli incidenti che
cambiano definitivamente la vita delle
persone perché è matthew fonte mori
oltre a una distorsione al ginocchio si
procurano una frattura scomposta del
femore che viene scalpellato in un
intervento e questo lo rende claudicante
per tutta la vita per cui da giovane che
sognava di solcare i mari viene
costretto e viene diciamo così
retrocesso dalla marina americana a capo
di un ufficio che non nome un po
impolverato depth of char sinistro mens
il deposito delle carte degli strumenti
che di fatto non era altro
niente proprio di più e niente poco di
meno che l'archivio che conteneva tutti
i diari di bordo dei mercantili dei
capitani che avevano solcato le acque
dell'oceano atlantico attraverso i loro
viaggi che contenevano questi diari di
bordo informazioni preziosissime sulla
direzione dei venti sulle precipitazioni
sulla direzione delle correnti che però
è già c'erano appunto impolverati in
fondo a questo deposito
matthew fontainemore e oltre alla
passione per il mare a un'altra passione
che è quella per la statistica e per i
numeri e infatti non a caso viene
considerato ancora oggi il padre di una
parola che è sulla bocca di tutti i big
data perché quello che da che da inizio
con la sua opera è proprio un opera di
strutturazione di dati perché costruisce
un team di quelle che neanche a farlo
apposta venivano chiamati computers
coloro che contano che sono delle
persone che prendono i diari e
sostanzialmente imputano tutti i dati
che trovano al loro interno è un'opera
di inventariato colossale 1.250.000
osservazioni che però a questo punto
diventano da dato destrutturato
un'informazione quantitativa che può
essere utilizzata per un'applicazione
questa applicazione è la è la
realizzazione del primo atlante
contenente le mappe nautiche che
consentono di navigare l'oceano
atlantico
questa però non è nemmeno tutta la sua
storia quella che stiamo raccontando ne
è solo un pezzo della storia
e allora questa potrebbe diventare la
storia di un giovane pittore che vedete
ritratto alle mie spalle
allora non vi sembrava molto giovane
perché in questa foto
in realtà è già molto affermato resto
tra poco se non l'avete già riconosciuto
vi svelerò di chi si tratta è una
persona che però fa parte della nostra
storia perché nel 1825 di rientro dal
classico viaggio di formazione in europa
allora appunto dei giovani pittori
venivano in europa per studiare l'arte
rinascimentale l'arte europea e poi
facevano tesoro di quanto appreso per
cercare di sbarcare il lunario con la
pittura torna negli stati uniti e gli
viene commissionato tra le tante opere
un ritratto che è quello che vedete qui
dietro di me che rappresenta una figura
fondamentale della storia sia americana
sia francese marchese lafayette nel 1825
mentre sta dipingendo questo ritratto il
pittore riceve una lettera che contiene
una notizia ferale perché nella lettera
in scritto che la moglie giace in punto
di morte sul letto
a questo punto le distante da washington
con una cavalcata epica e drammatica
insieme cerca di raggiungere la moglie
per
salutarla prima della morte ma la
cavalcata è vana arriva che la moglie
già defunta e quindi accanto alla
passione per la pittura questo giovane
pittore sviluppa anche una passione è
un'ossessione per un altro problema che
è quello della comunicazione a distanza
cioè chiede a se stesso e poi
all'umanità come non sia possibile
trovare un modo per comunicare in modo
più veloce e messaggi a distanza
sviluppa una passione da autodidatta che
lo trasforma nel padre della telegrafia
moderna perché di fatto il signore di
cui aveva mostrato la foto e samuel
morse che poi ha dato origine al codice
morse che è appunto il codice utilizzato
per trasmettere messaggi a lunga
distanza
eppure questa non è neanche soltanto la
storia di questo giovane pittore e
allora potrebbe diventare la storia di
una donna d'altri tempi di cui ancora vi
mostrerò le fiji che magari dirà poco ai
più
ora vi dirò il nome si chiama anche
isabella milbank che magari dice poco
anche questo però è più famosa con il
nome di lei di byron cioè la moglie del
grande poeta inglese è anche madre di
ada lovelace che è stata e viene
considerata un po la madre
dell'informatica moderna e del computer
ma questa letteralmente diventerebbe un
altra storia per cui perché parliamo di
lei di byron perché il nome di là di
byron compare tra i sottoscrittori di
capitale nel 1858 che serve a finanziare
la spedizione per la costruzione di
questo cavo di cui stiamo raccontando la
storia come i venture capital di oggi i
business angel di oggi le di byron ed è
tra gli investitori che crede in questo
progetto mette i suoi soldi e me li
perde tutti perché la spedizione del
1858 si rivela fallimentare
e allora arrivato il momento di mettere
insieme tutte queste storie attraverso
quella che ne fa da cornice che è la
storia di un baby pensionato della metà
dell'ottocento che è questo giovane uomo
qui ritratto più o meno all'età di 35
anni a new york dove abitava si chiama
syrus westfield ed era appunto un baby
pensionato perché a metà dell'ottocento
era diventato ricchissimo avendo gestito
con enorme profitto una cartiera che lo
aveva reso tra gli uomini più abbienti
della città di new york dal medico
curante viene sostanzialmente
consigliata ritirarsi a vita privata
perché con diceva conduceva una vita
troppo intensa e quindi si rose
westfield si ritira a vita privata ma
non è capace di stare seduto
letteralmente in una lettera il fratello
dice che se c'era una posizione in cui
stava scomodo syrus era seduto su una
poltrona comincia a dare il la a una
serie di attività filantropiche tra cui
il finanziare progetti che ritiene
meritorio in qualche modo innovativi
attraverso quella che è una parola che
anche questa è un po sulla bocca di
tutti serendipity trovare qualcosa che
non si stava necessariamente cercando
che in parte si fonda proprio
sull'ignoranza perché silos sfida
completamente ignorante di telegrafia e
un giorno gli si presenta a casa un
giovane ingegnere canadese frederik
hillesborg che gli propone uno di questi
progetti
cioè collegare con un cavo telegrafico
new york a new found land che oggi noi
conosciamo come terranova che è una
delle punte più estreme del canada
perché perché a metà del 1800 una
notizia perché venisse trasmessa da una
parte all'altra dell'oceano impiegava
almeno due settimane doveva viaggiare
per mare ovviamente attraverso viaggi
anche molto pericolosi quindi costruire
un telegrafo che collegasse new york al
canada avrebbe consentito di risparmiare
qualche giorno nella comunicazione tra
europa e stati uniti 6 rus però forte
della sua ignoranza serendipità se mi
consentite questa brutta espressione in
realtà non rimane particolarmente
colpito da questo progetto è appunto
puntando la sua mano sul mappamondo che
oggi ha conservato dello smithsonian
institute dice ma a me fondamentalmente
di collegare new york a new found land
interessa relativamente poco non mi
sembra poi questa grande innovazione
perché non proviamo direttamente a
collegare new york o comunque il
continente americano a londra il
silenzio con cui sta accogliendo questa
proposta più o meno quello che deve aver
provato ginsborg sentendo questa
proposta pazza si alza e se ne va però
mettiamo insieme le storie che abbiamo
raccontato prima perché
cosa fa immediatamente siro suoi film
scrive due lettere una a quel matthew
fontainemore e di cui abbiamo raccontato
la storia poc'anzi che è il padre
dell'oceanografia moderna chiedendogli
come funziona il fondo dell'oceano
atlantico cioè il fondo dell'oceano
atlantico è adatto per ospitare un cavo
sottomarino che unisca due punti così
distanti come new york londra e la
seconda lettera
indovinate un po la scrive samuel morse
il padre della telegrafia moderna per
chiedere se posto che abbiamo passato
questo cavo tra new york e londra il
messaggio telegrafico che passa sotto la
profondità dell'oceano arriva sano e
salvo
bene da entrambe le persone riceve
almeno a livello teorico disco verde e
quindi l'avventura parte e l'avventura
parte coi bindini come si suol dire
quindi parte un enorme campagna di fund
raising di cui la di byron è un appunto
dei finanziatori con dei numeri che io
vi snocciola in rapida sequenza sono
impressionanti ma non riescono a
restituire tutta l'audacia di questa
sfida perché vengono prodotti 45.000 km
di cavo di rame
perché questa non è una spedizione che
avviene come una passeggiata
servono tante spedizioni in tanti
fallimenti per arrivare al successo
definitivo 1.600 tonnellate di peso di
questo capo che poi viene caricato su
delle navi che posano il cavolo il cavo
sul fondo dell'oceano atlantico 250
operai impiegati full time per 11 mesi
12 anni tra sogni speranze ma anche
cocenti delusioni perché questa è una
serie di spedizioni molte delle quali
sono costellate dal più amaro dei
fallimenti tre spedizioni ufficiali il
tutto per un messaggio che viene inviato
con successo nel 1858 in quella
spedizione che poi si rivela
fallimentare prima di quella definitiva
che avrà successo
un messaggio che viene mandato da una
parte all'altra dell'oceano e che ha per
protagonisti due grandi personaggi
dell'epoca la regina vittoria che era a
capo dell'impero britannico di allora e
james buchanan che era il presidente
degli stati uniti allora perché da
subito questa spedizione diventa anche
un evento a geo politico fondamentale il
primo messaggio ufficiale e dei due capi
di stato
pensate un po quanto ci vuole per
trasmettere questo messaggio non
tantissimo 17 ore e 40 minuti
questo è il tempo che viene impiegato
per la trasmissione di questo primo
messaggio che però è veramente la a
questo villaggio globale in cui ancora
oggi noi siamo immersi
perché oggi che lo sappiate o meno
ancora una gran parte delle nostre
comunicazioni passa attraverso cavi
sottomarini oggi sono cavi in fibra
ottica ma la tecnologia nasce un po da
quelle ideali oggi 84 miliardi di parole
al secondo vengono scambiate attraverso
i nostri device che si tratti di
smartphone e tablet
oggi parliamo di rivoluzione digitale e
oggi appunto il 70 per cento delle
comunicazioni ancora salvo quelle che
passano attraverso satellite passa
attraverso cavi sottomarini google e
facebook tra le altre big companies
hanno appena finanziato un progetto di
un cavo sottomarino che verrà costruito
e posato in giappone per migliorare di
qualche milionesimo di secondo la
trasmissione delle informazioni
nell'era in cui le informazioni i dati
sono il nuovo petrolio è chiaro che
diventa fondamentale la velocità nelle
trasmissioni
mi piace però pensare e raccontare la
storia che di fatto ha un po dato il là
a tutta questa incredibile avventura e
mi piace concludere questo gomitolo di
storie con una citazione che chiosa bene
il racconto di syros west il perché dice
che chi dice che è una cosa impossibile
non dovrebbe disturbare chi la sta
facendo
la frase attribuita insieme a passami il
sale a tante altre ad albert einstein è
veramente del grande fisico
pare di no ma se noi oggi abbiamo uno
strumento come vuoti investigator che ci
consente in pochi secondi di verificare
la paternità di un affermazione
l'attribuzione della stessa a qualche
grande personaggio meno e anche grazie
alla follia e ambizione di personaggi
come syros westfield che mentre oggi ci
sono persone che nello stesso paese
vogliono costruire muri per separare
paesi allora vedeva veramente molto
lungo e puntava ad abbattere barriere ea
costruire quel villaggio globale in cui
ancora non e oggi siamo immersi grazie
[Applauso]